what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with fall of X
and I'm really excited to see what you
guys think about the ending of this
video because it's very exciting it's
very very exciting so what this does is
this picks up in the aftermath of what
we had previously covered which is to
say Sebastian Shaw who was at one point
not really a member of the X-Men but the
mutant Community now that he's basically
been cast out of the hellfire club
meaning he has no real influence of any
kind he's just a guy out there in the
world trying to avoid capture by the
human population that he's basically
been putting together Crews to try to
plunder krakowa right because remember
all 250 000 mutants that were on krakowa
have basically been sent off the island
but Charles Xavier the leader of the
X-Men is one of the only guys left in
fact he's the only guy who's currently
occupying the island previously they'd
sent in a group of mercenaries to try to
plunder it and then of course they came
across Xavier and he helped them to
understand their place in the bigger
picture in the follow-up to this Celine
steps in and then basically absorbs
their Essence their memories and then
tells Sebastian Shaw what's going on now
Celine is one of the coolest mutants in
Marvel comics who's kind of a mutant but
not really a mutant sort of it's one of
those weird finicky things but you never
really get to see her that much and in
fact she really hasn't had a major role
in Marvel since the X in the crochet
storyline back in 2010 she has appeared
and she's done some stuff but she just
hasn't really been on a grand stage
Celine is by all standards of
measurement the oldest mutant to ever
exist in the history of Marvel Comics
she's like 17
000 years old and she's technically an
external so for those of you guys who
are familiar with this bear with me here
for a second I want to explain this for
people who are not externals are not to
be confused with eternals eternal is the
result of just humans who at one point
in time their genes were modified by
celestials and they basically got like
Cosmic abilities and so on and so forth
externals are mutants who are
legitimately Immortal they're not
indestructible you can destroy their
physical form but when I say Immortal I
mean to say they cannot age they will
never get sick right they will just live
on forever so long as you don't find a
way to decapitate them or something
along those lines Wolverine for example
with his healing Factor You could argue
he's an external even though he's
technically not when it comes to Celine
she isn't external but she's not in the
sense that she has to absorb other
people's life energies in order to keep
herself alive but what she does when
that happens is she absorbs their
memories and everything that makes them
who they are with this happening
Sebastian Shaw realizes Xavier's still
on the island and they can find a way
around them so what he ends up doing is
basically sending in another group this
time they have mental blocks in place or
devices that prevent Xavier from
seemingly being able to influence their
minds we'll actually find out it doesn't
work but what we end up doing here
before we get into that part is we
switch over to Exodus now remember
Exodus is this just ridiculously
powerful telepath and and telekinetic
and Marvel Comics he's an Omega Level
mutant that's leading 250 000 mutants
those individuals who walk through the
portals and seemingly disappeared off of
all known planes of existence he's
leading them to what he calls Paradise
but there is no actual destination he's
not really leading them anywhere in
particular he's just giving them hope
until such a time that an opportunity
presents itself that they can all
effectively be rescued but as a
testament to this guy's a level of power
what he realizes is that the longer
they're in the desert the more likely
they are to succumb to the elements
which is to say the very harsh heat in
the daytime the very cold temperatures
in the nighttime the lack of water the
lack of food and so what's been
happening here is he's been basically
using his telekinesis to pull water out
of the air right and then in turn
deposit it into a location where people
can basically drink the other part of
this is that mutants out there that have
regenerative capabilities or simply just
generative capabilities in and of
themselves meaning they can alter plant
matter or they can kind of create
something out of nothing but not really
they're basically generating things that
people can consume for example there's
one mutant out there that can generate
glucose right the very Foundation of
what you and I would call carbohydrates
if my knowledge of diet is correct which
is probably not because I'm in terrible
shape but the thing about this is that
they basically find ways to kind of keep
each other alive but understand not
everyone is equipped for this right 250
000 mutants here a majority of these
guys have basic powers like wings that
come out of their back and they can fly
right or like they can see at night or
something along those lines and while
those powers are useful in certain
situations they're largely useless in
this situation because the name of the
game here is survival and so what ends
up happening is that hope summer is one
of the only known members of the five
capable of resurrecting mutants in fact
the other four are basically missing she
asks Exodus how long he can keep this up
because despite how powerful he is he
can't do this forever virtually every
mutant out there needs to rest in some
capacity somewhere along the line but
because the powers of Hope Summers is to
copy the powers of the people around her
she can basically take its place so they
can literally just do shifts right they
can just kind of take it in turns to
create water or whatever resources are
available that their powers can use in
order to bring some measure of
sustenance to people but it's one of
those interesting things because what
you end up getting is basically a really
kind of a minor mutant by the name of
Kafka who's kind of doing what is in
effect Patrol Duty right like they're
all just taking it in shifts to keep an
eye out in case there happen to be
Predators because remember we don't know
where they are and we don't know when
they are they can't be detected by
Xavier which means they're not currently
on Earth the idea here is that they seem
to be in some other dimension that
exists out there but we don't really
know what it is the issue here is that
as Kafka is doing his patrols he comes
across A variation of Wolverine this
attacking mother righteous now do you
guys know how I feel about mother
righteous after reading the comments you
guys seem to love Mother righteous I
don't fully understand why
but hey it is what it is the funny thing
here though is that these do not seem to
be the same versions of Wolverine that
we've been seeing in the Wolverine solo
series kind of a little side here uh
that whole thing with like beasts and
all that kind of stuff that's basically
taken a backseat to a degree while they
went into weapons of Vengeance once that
story is done we'll go back into the
whole Beast Wolverines that storyline
and all that kind of stuff right so just
be aware that that's happening here for
those of you guys who are curious but of
course one of them immediately goes
after a cough cut right and in fact
actually chases him down as he gets over
to Exodus and those guys the question
they have here is where did these
Wolverines come from here's a hint it's
not mother righteous you would be
inclined to believe that it is right
she's very duplicitous she's very
manipulative right but it's not actually
her there's somebody out here in this
desert that's sending these forces out
there in order to test the entirety of
the mutant population that should give
you a hint if if you cannot pick up that
hint I don't know what to tell you I
told you the ending is dope so what this
does is the mutants basically respond
pretty readily and in fact it's Exodus
who's the one that basically takes them
out incredibly fast and a lot of this is
because of one the nature of his powers
but two they see him as a leader right
the guy who is leading the entirety of
the group and that happens right it's
one of the cool things about this story
and the way that it's written in times
of desperation people will believe what
they want to believe and in the absence
of an ordered government people will
turn to Warlords Petty strongman anybody
who can grant them some measure of
safety and so Exodus provides them
exactly that it also helps he was on the
quiet Council right the governing body
of krakowa before the entire fall of the
mutant population but it's one of those
things where you have mother righteous
who kind of shows up here and then
basically reveals to everybody that
she's a mutant now we've known this for
a little while we didn't necessarily
know how far reaching it was is she
actually had a mutant Gene she's a clone
of a guy named Mr sinister sinister
himself was never a mutant in Marvel
Comics in fact in the old stories The
Adventures of Cyclops and Phoenix he was
just a human who had his genes Modified
by apocalypse and became Sinister but
there is a lot of changing going on here
in Marvel Comics with regards to the
traditional roles that various
characters have the idea behind mother
righteous though and what makes her
really intriguing here is that she never
knew that she was actually a mutant and
in fact it wasn't until Xavier was
forced to use his telepathy to make all
250 000 mutants on gracoa walk through
the portals that she was able to
successfully walk through one of the
krakowan gates and only mutants can do
that so that was kind of like the okay
she's a mutant now that's kind of wild
but the kicker about all this is we have
to assume she's telling the truth we
don't know where she is she's a very
manipulative person and she lies in
order to achieve her own ends so we have
no clue if she's actually telling the
truth but what's interesting is she
talks about how for her she uses magic
but her ability to use magic is
something that's self-taught she just
learned over the years much in the same
way than Stephen Strange learned to use
magic and became Doctor Strange she's
not nearly as powerful but her mutant
Gene whatever it happens to be or at
least whatever Powers it happens to
manifest we don't really know what it is
right and in fact even in this moment
when Hope Summers scans the entire
biology of mother righteous even that
it's just nebulous right her response is
she is a mutant her gift is really
diffuse like legion's gift but
microscopic many gifts none of them
solid maybe you have huge potential now
the reason why she uses Legion as an
example here is that for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar Legion is
arguably the most powerful mutant to
ever exist in Marvel Comics not so much
because of what he's able to do in and
of himself right somebody like Franklin
Richards or magic of Jaspers or Matthew
Malloy they have reality altering powers
that we just see them perform what makes
Legion so incredibly powerful is that
he's got thousands of personalities and
each one has a power some of these
powers are exactly the same other powers
are different but he has everything
ranging from the ability to time travel
high levels of telepathy and telekinesis
personalities like the origamis can bend
reality Moira X can actually alter
reality right there's different versions
of himself that can do different things
and it's just crazy how powerful he is
he just seemingly can't control it all
right but the idea is that if he ever
could control all those Powers he'd be
as close as anybody could ever get to
becoming God and so what is up happening
is Mother righteous doesn't necessarily
usurp the authority of Exodus instead
she does what she always does which is
kind of the slow creep of power now
before we get into that jumping back to
the island where these guys show up here
with basically anti-siotics right so
effectively the ability ability to block
out the telepathy of Xavier the funny
thing about this is Xavier's
underestimated yet again we don't
exactly see what happens right once he
sees them he's like antipsiotics very
well and where they go to open fire all
you see that happens next is they're
literally just Torn to Pieces
decapitated cut in half their guts
ripped out all kinds of stuff we don't
exactly know what it was that did this
because in the previous instance where
we saw Xavier using his powers he was
using his telepathy to force these guys
to see things that weren't actually
there but something that simply exists
in your mind but does not exist in the
tangible world could seemingly not
really do any damage to you right it was
just enough to scare them whatever's
going on here Marvel looks like they're
moving in the direction of either
Xavier's telepathy is on a whole new
level right he's just unleashing in a
way that we've never seen him do before
which is the most likely candidate or
they're giving him like telekinesis
right they're giving him like some new
powers or the ability to manifest
monsters whatever it is in the physical
world we don't fully know but I am
excited to find out having said that and
jumping back to Mother righteous once
she meets with Exodus she really just
kind of presents to them this sort of
Utopia that looks very similar to The
Savage land which is to say a jungle
Paradise in a place where a jungle
Paradise shouldn't exist nobody here
really questions it because in a lot of
ways they see it as a kind of Salvation
And so they're not really going to look
a gift horse in the mouth but understand
mother righteous is not doing this
seemingly because it's just altruistic
she always has a bigger plan there's
always something that she's doing this
is why I say the slow move of power
creep because seemingly what she's doing
here is kind of usurping the authority
of Exodus that where Exodus says I will
lead all of you to Paradise I will lead
all of you to the place that we can call
home and whatever this place happens to
be until such a time as we can return to
our actual home the reality is Mother
righteous is the one that presents her
yourself here and she's the one that
really shows them this place now that's
easy to dismiss and you can say well I
mean Exodus led us to her and she's the
one that LEDs to this but like she's
gonna make a power move somewhere along
the line but in the midst of all of this
Exodus makes a statement where he says
be careful what you wish for the testing
has barely begun the Logan's are dogs
wild animals in the Wasteland but they
are far from the greatest threat do not
forget the desert is also the home of
Satan and what it shows us is apocalypse
seemingly apocalypse is in this place
and he's going to test them over and
over and over again he's gonna weed out
and kill off the weakest mutants leaving
only the strongest to survive I am very
excited to see what happens because my
main man is finally back with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end if you guys need to get caught up on
fall of X make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later
peace